[Music]
ah
can we get you anything chris that's a
black coffee please yeah we'll sort that
out
you are here right
now yeah yeah yeah
thank you
nice to meet you nice to meet you man
i love the jacket
what was that wow i feel like i'm in
game of thrones
i don't know if this has happened to you
i'm pretty sure it has done you're
watching tv
and you're like wow this guy is amazing
and then like
i'm a real boy you're here i exist
you're in front of a
this is chris jericho but you got to be
professional though man i can't be
professional well you have to be [__]
freaking out right [__] you we we're
here you're i'm now on your show as a
guest this is mendel of you guys yeah so
this is cool but just be cool do your
thing this is why i'm here because you
guys have 1.9 million youtube
subscribers certainly two hopefully
almost two million after this show is
done yeah you'll have two members you've
got to take it over the top that's it so
we're here let's [__] rock it man you
can do it you saw the king of youtube
numbers in a way because when you look
at your youtube especially your music
numbers you're absolutely killing it
there's like over 50 million views on
for judas i think yeah 55 million 57 57
yeah but then what did i just see the
other day i saw a video
oh ac dc thunderstruck right 1 billion
views it's incredible so it kind of puts
things in perspective it's like yes
we're doing really good unless you're
listening to thunderstruck 57 million is
like that's almost unimaginable i
remember when when the video we did the
video for judas it was i guess probably
almost five years ago
and one of the girls that was in the
video said how many views do you hope
this gets and at the time i think we had
a a a video that had a million and i was
thinking if this one can get to three
million yeah
that'll be awesome
now we're at 57 million so we crushed
that goal so yeah it's and that's kind
of the way of the world now how many
views do you have how many followers do
you have that sort of a thing so i
suppose it's always been that way but
now we can track it well yeah yeah
exactly you can track it and so now when
you see those numbers and that actually
is currency in this day and age so so
when you say you know how many spotify
numbers do you have how many you know
youtube views you have and judas
just went gold in the states which means
500 000 units sold jesus but nowadays
nobody buys music anymore right
so it's all based on streams
how many streams do you need for the
equivalent of 500 000 units sold
75 million streams [__] think about that
75 million streams equals 500 000. it's
[__] up right i mean really
music artists are surely getting a raw
end of the deal huge drawing of the deal
right yeah you don't make money off
albums and music anymore right it's all
about kind of like i said the streams i
think for each stream it's a point zero
zero zero one cent so anyways that's
just that's how it is nowadays uh so
music is now just basically
a billboard
for your band you put out a record
knowing that you're not going to make
money off it but hoping that people
listen to it to come see your shows and
buy the merch and all that sort of thing
so things have changed but it's just the
way it is so there you go that's your
there's your lesson on streaming ladies
and gentlemen appreciate it and also
when it comes to music whenever
obviously i met you as chris jericho the
wrestler right and then late i found out
about fuzzy and the band and everything
like that but
you know when you hear like someone
who's good at one thing wants to do
music like we've we've seen this with
youtubers doing music in this country
you're immediately a bit like
oh is this what's this going to sound
like there's always people are thinking
like oh it's some kind of novelty thing
yes you know a vanity project and we've
heard it all before trust me i've heard
it all before i was surprised like when
i actually listened for example to judas
i was like oh well and that's the thing
i wouldn't i wouldn't do this for 20
years as a vanity product yeah and i
wouldn't do it if it sucked you know
good music is good music it doesn't
matter if the singer is a wrestler a
butcher a baker a candlestick maker who
gives a [__] that lasts for the
you know the time frame of one minute of
a song it's just like slipknot wears
masks oh that looks stupid how good can
they be kiss wears makeup how good can
they be
ac dc as a schoolboy how stupid is that
doesn't matter
uh once the music plays then it's either
good music or bad music and i think
that's one of the reasons why fozzie has
really gotten to the next level now is
that people know now for sure it's like
not some kind of
you know side project or
um you know it's it's just a great rock
and roll band with great songs and great
live shows and who cares if chris
jericho's a wrestler i don't care that
bruce dickinson is an airline pilot when
iron maiden plays a show i don't want
him to tell me about how to fly a plane
conversely if i'm on a plane and bruce
is the pilot i don't want to hear him
sing run to the hills i want him to fly
fly the [__] plane and make sure i
want both i want both at the same time
you're demanding yeah uh hey i've paid
to be in business
my point is fly the plane sing the songs
wrestle the match sing the songs
we don't really combine the two nor
should you because they're two separate
entities and there's something i talked
to rob zombie about this on my podcast
when he started making movies people
were angry
how can you how is rob zombie gonna make
a movie he's a singer what does he know
about making movies that's such a stupid
attitude to have
how can chris jericho sing when he's a
wrestler what does what what does that
even [__] mean
what does that mean because you're one
thing you can't do something else and i
think in this day and age more than ever
people do
both uh and what i mean both they do
more than one thing you find that people
who are good at doing more than one
thing are also good at reinventing
themselves at one thing as well and
that's one thing that you've done
amazingly well like your career being 30
plus years now in wrestling
i i watched this documentary about you
before today and i just seen like how
many iterations and how you're
constantly
right what's the next version of me
why are you so good at that well first
of all thank you um why i don't know i i
think
um
so i'm a huge david bowie fan and not
necessarily even like knowing every
bowie song and every album
just the concept of what
bowie did we always reinvented himself
and you look at ziggy stardust to
aladdin saying to the thin white duke to
the tin machine to the button button eye
it was always something new
always reinventing you could dress up as
david bowie for halloween
and i could dress up as dave and you can
dress up as and we have everybody's
wearing a different costume but you know
who it is right yeah and that's one
thing that i always wanted to do with
chris jericho it's like you can dress up
as jericho every halloween i post
pictures of people who dress up as me
but they're all different versions of
jericho there's 10 different versions
that you can dress up as that comes from
bowie and the reason is i never wanted
to be a nostalgia act even 20 years ago
on raw when we had i was looking at raw
and smackdown or like okay it's live
twice a week every week
that's like 104
shows a year
if i'm doing the same thing every show
it gets boring quickly and you become
kind of nostalgic and if i leave
the company for a while and come back
and do the same thing it's boring and so
i never wanted to do that so
probably on the other side of the coin i
change and evolve whenever i start
feeling just a little bit stale i always
call it reading the room i read the room
what's the or how are the fans reacting
you know now social media is a very
valuable tool
to judge how people are reacting to what
you're doing you know people complain
about everything that's fine always
angry about something but when they
start talking in a way where i can think
they're starting to get bored of me
time to change it up
and so i never have a problem with
people like oh we love y2j and we love
the list and we love you know this
those are great moments and great points
in my career but i will never go back to
it i will never go back to it because
it's done if i go back to it it doesn't
feel right it doesn't feel real
it doesn't mean it's any less cool but
you have to move forward at least i have
to move forward with everything that i
do and have these great moments in the
past but they stay in the past because
they're a product of their time i
couldn't do y2j in 2022 because that was
a product of 1999 but needed to be that
year didn't it yeah yeah
and it was a great
kind of tagline in wwe
but then in 2008 when i turned into the
suit and tie
guy bad guy jericho i said don't ever
call me ytj again on commentary there is
no more ytj and there's no more
countdown and there's all those things
that were kind of synonymous with
jericho it's done what do you mean i
don't ever want you to [__] call me
ytj on commentary again because that's
done we need to move forward and let
people know this is a new character it's
a new guy how do people react to that
because
they hated it first i mean not the
public but within the company because
you've built a very strong brand and
like other wrestlers yeah undertaker
people like that they're known for
certain things but undertaker changed
too absolutely
undertaker he was very good
at being almost a bowie style character
in wrestling of still staying the
undertaker but changing the vibe of it
you can't do the same thing
every
show every week every month every year
it just gets stale and the last thing
you want to be as a performer whether
it's music or wrestling or comedy or
football or whatever it is the last
thing you want is to be stale
and
i'm really good
at
smelling the staleness before anybody
else does and changing so it looks like
i'm ahead of the curve rather than being
behind it but i always can like i said
when you smell that staleness
it's not very very uh
it doesn't take long for for everyone
else to it could be a week like it could
be two weeks and when it happens it
happens quick and then you kind of get
put into the
also ran category i never wanted to be
there when i look at you
doing that compared to some other
top guys in the business
i feel like you have really done that
better than them like when i look at the
rock
no disrespect but the rock's basically
played the same character in every movie
for the last 15 years and he's been the
same wrestler for the last 20. um that's
no disrespect it's an amazing trick but
it's people are obsessed with it but i
don't know i find it it's a skill in
itself what you've managed to do looking
back at um when you did start off
against the rock
what an entrance that was like that was
they they called that the greatest debut
in the history of wrestling you've had
quite a lot of these moments that people
go
that was the best that we've seen the
first time that anyone's been undisputed
how does it feel looking back at your
career now knowing you've had all those
moments like
well i mean it's always cool to look
back at those things
um and maybe you know someday
well actually i was gonna say sitting in
a rocking chair on the porch which i'll
never do [__] kill me if i ever do
that um
what will you do
i'll just dude i saw the stones on
sunday at hyderabad and like that's
that's me i look at mick
and
he's not just oh he's he's so good for
seven no he's just [__] good they're
just a great rock and roll band and the
best rock and roll band and i see a lot
of concerts and listen to a lot of music
and the stones are still the best not
for their i hate that the stones are so
good for h [__] that they're [__]
good for any age any age and any rock
and roll band needs to bow down to the
greatness of the stones and also to the
inspiration that you get from watching
them
so i see mick and the energy that he has
and
it's like that's this is going to be me
at 78. um whatever i'm doing in
entertainment i've been i've been in
entertainment since i was 19 years old
it's like in show business that that's
what wrestling is at show business
so um
anyways to answer your question
looking back on those big moments
is always cool and that's one thing i
like about social media is they'll say
today today
i had
one of the greatest matches of my career
against ultimo dragon in tokyo that was
the match that essentially got me into
ecw and wcw it happened 27 years ago
today
i would never know that except for
social media so sometimes those
anniversaries come up you're like [__]
that's really cool and then i go back
and think about that match and maybe
watch some highlights of it and you're
like man
that was a good match or that was a good
entrance with the rock but i don't
you know plant my flag in it and and
think that was the greatest moment of my
career because it was one of many
and when people say
what's the greatest incarnation of chris
jericho i always say this one right now
because if i say oh the the y2j was the
best or the list guy was the best or the
suit and tie gaggers was the best that
would infer that what i'm doing right
now sucks
so what's the best chris jericho right
now i mean that's the that's the point
of evolving and i agree with you you've
clearly taken it in your levels and but
it's up to nothing but it's up to
the fans and the people that appreciate
my work you guys decide what your
favorite jericho was and you can choose
anyone you want to it's that that's your
right and i love the fact that there's
all these errors that you can choose but
to me
i have to stay current and have to stay
in the now and i really do believe that
the chris jericho now is my favorite
because there's so many great things
happening so that's my opinion you have
yours you have yours and that's the
beauty of being a fan of wrestling or
music or anything you can choose
whatever you want i like the next chris
jericho for the next one really good
one of the themes behind
your career i feel is pushing the
boundaries and and pushing up against
authority and if and when i watch these
all these documentaries i've watched
about you know i see these documentaries
they're very good they're fun
they're very good
and it seems like you got pissed off a
lot by being held back now obviously the
wa
favored the monsters the giants and you
came from a different angle of not you
weren't a small guy but obviously your
attributes were different to this
and it felt like
just when i thought you
were the guy that they were going to
push and they did hold you back a little
bit and it does feel like there was a
lot of frustrations there over the years
what is it like to feel
i i should be the guy now but yet they
won't let me just run with it i never
like
obviously you would have frustrations
but it's business and you have to be a
big boy you know what i mean
uh
the wwe is a giant
machine
and
it's run by vince mcmahon obviously it's
an it's it's an audience of one
it was yeah it really it really is i
mean you have to be
vince has to
want to make you the guy it doesn't
matter if a million people want you to
be the guy if vince doesn't see it
you're not it doesn't matter if a
million people don't want you to be the
guy if vince wants it it happens so i
had been in the business for nine years
before i got to wwe and had worked on
top in all those companies and countries
japan mexico you know
ecw
wcw and i wasn't like the world champion
but you can once again you know how to
navigate you know how to play the game
and you understand the politic
side of wrestling so i was you know at
times when when you feel held back or
all those things
yeah it was there but i also knew it was
like tough luck [__] pull up your
pants and be a big boy jericho like
this is just the way it is
so i always strive to do better
and that's why i think in 2008
when
i keep referencing suit and tie guy
jericho
that was the first time in eight years
of working for events that he saw
in me what i saw in me this guy can be
the guy and i was the guy in that
company in 2008-2009 i called myself the
best in the world at that time and i
believed it
not every night but most the time
there's nobody in the world that's
better than chris jericho as a pro
wrestler go to japan give me [__] all
the names from there or whatever else
nobody's better than me and i think
that's when vince felt the same so it
took a while but i earned that spot
and never
you can't go into it with bitterness and
thinking they owe me this the business
owes you nothing that's the number one
rule that we learned in in the heart
brothers camp in 1990
the business owes you nothing so don't
ever think that you [__]
are worthy of a career deserve a career
because you have to keep working always
i'm working my ass off now
owes me nothing oh you're chris jericho
who gives a [__]
great i'm chris jericho but i still
because i'm chris jericho there's still
a level of quality that i have to bring
to the table to continue to keep
the spot that i have i have to earn it
every day there's no sitting back and
resting on your laurels in pro wrestling
or any job because when you start
feeling that way that's when you start
going down and then you're like well i'm
chris jericho i deserve this you don't
deserve anything
you deserve what you're getting and what
you're giving at any uh at the given
moment of right now here in 2022. so
yes there was frustrating times but in
the background
i'm better than this they don't see it
yet
but they will
because i did it in japan and i did it
in mexico and i did all these places
working on tops when i got to wwe even
there were there were times when
things sucked i still knew i know how to
do this and they will see it soon enough
and they did the vince mcmahon thing's
interesting he's going through a lot
right now
uh
what do you make because it's kind of
storyline comes reality like we watch
this guy joke around about
getting into compromising positions with
employees and tris stratos spending over
in front of him and all these funny
moments of people kissing his ass in the
middle of the ring and now all of a
sudden um
it's it's alleged that you know he paid
someone off a good few million to keep
quiet after an affair
is there surprise within the wrestling
industry that that happened not really i
mean is there a surprise in any industry
when it happens and and really
you know when you look at it
it's really not illegal he had an affair
paid the lady off to not say anything
and moved on so it's almost like
okay and
um people want to jump on it but there's
still always a
undertone of it's wrestling i was just
wrestling and if you look that story
came out with a bang and then you really
haven't heard anything about it since if
this was you know hollywood with harvey
weinstein and that sort of thing but the
difference between that was he was
holding women back from getting gigs
harvey weinstein either bang me or you
don't get the starring role this has
never been said in vince's thing there
was a mutual acknowledgment of this
affair and then he paid the lady to say
nothing and she took the money so
you know i i
really know vince well
and
it sucks that
it happened it sucks that he did it but
is anything really going to happen from
it i really don't think so he's putting
a public uh front on he's he said you're
not acting like someone who's got
anything to be ashamed of he never does
well he never does the fact that he
walked out on smackdown straight away
and announced smackdown as if to say i'm
what that's insane yeah and then he then
he was at the ufc on the weekend like
what are you gonna do it up yeah yeah
and like i said i think that it'll come
and go um and once again is it morally
right absolutely not
is it illegal no
is it something that is gonna get him in
real trouble i don't think so because
once again unfortunately oh it's just
vince mcmahon it's just wrestling of
course he's gonna do that so you know
those things come and go and they happen
and it's too bad but i really think it
doesn't really matter in the long run
and you know six months from now i'll
either be right or i'll be wrong what's
your relationship been like with vince
like because i i always wonder what it's
like to try to make
uh at least a meaningful relationship or
a relationship where you have some
leverage with a billionaire who runs the
whole company who is this audience of
one
you know what i mean he's just a [__]
dude and yes he is
very intimidating and he's a billionaire
and he's you know the creator of this
massive
iconic company
but deep down he's just a dude that
likes to hang out likes a joke and likes
to drink but everybody that surrounds
him not everybody but so many people
he's surrounded by yes men as most guys
in that position are he doesn't want yes
man you know and i had a really good
relationship with him
i don't have much of a relationship with
him now because obviously i don't work
for him so there's a little bit of a
career issue but if i text him right now
he texts me back in five minutes
always
um i loved working for vince mcmahon
i love to vince would challenge me and
push me and i also laugh
when people say oh vince has lost it and
oh look at vince he's terrible booker
and all this other stuff maybe it's not
great sometimes but you're also dealing
with a guy who's been doing this for 40
years imagine doing this for 40 years i
remember when i left in 2005 i said i
need to get away and he said to me i
wish i could get away sometimes but i
can't like kind of wistfully for like
three seconds then he was back to vince
grant like of course it's hard to do
this job but what vince do does the best
and people don't know this unless you
really work closely with him
is that he used to say
uh like how am i supposed to do this
vince i don't know
i just booked the [__] you make it work
okay so then i'll come back with an idea
and i've got this perfectly
you know formulated idea and let's
pretend the idea is this is this water
bottle here right and
here it is vince here's my idea this
water bottle and it's half full and it
says ebian on it and it's gonna at this
fight it's gonna make [__] a million
dollars for us i know and he'll look at
it and think about the idea now most
people if we were talking right now and
i started thinking after about 30
seconds if you weren't on the air
you feel compelled to jump in
and talk
create
sound
don't do that with vince if he's
thinking
let him think he doesn't want to hear
your stupid you know small talk he'll
just sit there and sometimes it's 30
seconds and sometimes it's a minute it's
very uncomfortable but he's thinking and
then what he'll do is
take the water bottle
and like turn it
let's say
180 degrees
and then
you see this idea that i came up with
that i thought was brilliant and this
one little small
twist that he adds to it
makes it a from a good idea to a great
idea that's what that's the genius of
vixen man with me he never came up with
the genesis and the and the foundation
of the idea i would but when i would
present it to him he would add the one
little part that made it great and most
of the big hits and some of the stuff we
discussed already
was made great by just the little twists
that vince added to it like for example
the the the greatest entrance of all
time as you as you said
uh i i was at a
post office and there was a countdown
clock
countdown to the new millennium which
was like at the time three months
uh you know five days six hours twelve
minutes and ten seconds nine seconds
eight and it was just running this clock
and i was like that's the perfect way
for me to come into the wwe the
countdown clock
so um his addition to it was that the
countdown would hit zero
right in the middle of the rocks promo
that was the genius that he added i
never thought of that i would never
suggest that i just thought it would end
and you know
maybe at the beginning of the show or it
would end and i would appear he's like
it ends right in the middle of the rocks
countdown like just little things like
that like [__] that's the g that's
that's the classic part of it you know
y2j
i i was pitching to him as the name of
my finish and he's like no no that's not
the name you're finished that's that's
your name and it's like me like yeah
you're y2j and i was like really and
[__] man i mean people still chanted to
this day
little i thought of the idea and the and
the term y2j
he's the one who saw the overall picture
that's much more valuable
for for the name of you to be that so
that's kind of vince's genius is is the
twists and turns that he adds to these
ideas that make them really really great
just absolutely you guys have to go to
brazil for a [__] coffee or what yeah
actually it's actually coming up in the
lift right now really
it's a big production like jericho's
coffee i was expecting a butler to show
up with a silver
geo might come out with that it just
does
a giant giant cup of coffee no we're
actually roasting the beans ourselves
anyways go ahead the new guy who's
taking over the wrestling business
someone who you've worked with a lot
triple h uh he is he taking it over it
seems easy well i think i could be wrong
oh
vince is very much still hands-on which
is surprising me to me vince's mother
just passed away at 101 years old jesus
so i used to call triple h prince
charles
aha thank god it wasn't the other one
no but seriously prince charles is the
king right yeah uh until the queen
passes away and she's she's been [__]
30 40 years she's going anywhere as i
got triple h is the prince charles of
wrestling in that this will be so he's
supposed to take it over but
it might be a long time i think vince is
78 so it could be another 20 years so
and he's not going anywhere vince i i
don't think vince will ever give up the
throne he'll have to die before yeah i
agree that'd be a good storyline
right it kind of is yeah it seems like
shane has been passed over and it seems
like they're leaning more towards triple
h anyway
um well they were but then
then it seemed over the last six to
eight months that they kind of stepped
away from that so i mean i don't know i
don't work there anymore but yeah maybe
maybe
maybe he will be the heir apparent but
who knows there was rumors of him in uh
stephanie parting ways but that doesn't
look like what's happening because they
were seen together recently but um he's
good at the politicking though i think
isn't it thank you wow see
what we'll do is we'll cut that in as if
that came at the start of the pod
they'll keep it this is real you guys
want the real behind-the-scenes story
absolutely and part of it is that it
took you guys
30 minutes to get me a cup of [__]
coffee sorry no absolutely we like to
keep you guessing there was actually a
countdown in the back and we wanted it
the coffee countdown um but yeah so so
maybe he'll take over um when vince is
ready to leave his post aka when he dies
but it could be a long time it must be
difficult to balance all that like you
know obviously wrestling kind of takes
an element a huge element of ego right
well i think anything in show business
does but right yeah but with with say a
triple h and then obviously vince has
got his own ego there are a lot of
things to kind of manage yeah you know
all rubbing up against each other how
did you sort of fit into that because in
listening to you tell some of your
stories i always find it interesting
obviously you've got you know your ideas
you speak about wrestlemania 29 when you
had to bring in fandango and you kind of
you you're almost quite i think what a
lot of people appreciate you in this
long-winded monologue is that you
you're quite giving as a wrestler in
that sense and a lot of other people
appreciate that but you act as though
i'm like
such a great guy for being giving it's
your [__] job
like that's what the job is right and i
think that's one of the reasons why i've
been able to do this for so long at a
high level is
you have to be giving you have to create
new stars i remember back
when i first started it was like
you know no one's going to take my spot
and you can you know i don't want to
give up my spot and it's all about your
spot no nobody is taking chris jericho's
spot because nobody can do what i can do
there's only one chris jericho so
to
continue to stay relevant and to
continue to contribute and be a top guy
the
definition of that is to be giving to
create new stars when we started aw it
was solely on my back i really believe
that because if you look at the roster
unless you were a hardcore wrestling fan
no one [__] knew any of those guys i
didn't even know what aaw was and then i
heard that you were joining was like oh
what's this then so there's a perfect
example so chris jericho's there yeah
really i didn't even let's check it out
and then you see all the other you know
great guys but i knew right out of the
gate i have three to six months to make
as many stars as i can because if not i
can't
as great as
as i am and as great as i think i am
if i'm the only guy in the show for six
months and the only star it's gonna die
it is i can't i can't do it all i'm not
[__] you know michael jackson or
elvis or somebody like that so i knew
very quickly i had to create stars right
out of the gate and that's why we
concentrated on reinventing cody think
about cody when aw started he was not
the cody that he is now nobody knew
kenny omega was uh darby allen scorpio
sky
moxley he was not the guy that he is now
when he came into our company
excuse me jungle boy all of those guys i
worked with early on in the process
to let people know young bucks
inner circle the first night we created
in a circle to show
here's some new guys who's sammy guevara
i didn't know who santana ortiz was jake
hager was not the guy he is now he was a
a a a useless character in wwe
so we built these stars in three months
and that's when we got a television deal
for 160 million dollars for four years
when we started we were an ad revenue
share adrev is what it's called what
does that mean
any company that buys advertising on our
show we split it with the network
that's the money that we're making
you're not getting a dime what was the
split i don't know [__] so let's say
it's 50 50. whatever how much how much
how much is an ad cost 10 000
here's five grand what's five grand dude
nothing so in those three months
we built the company to where our demos
were so good and when i say that on the
demo god it's a real thing the demo is
the number one most important thing for
television revenue
and the demos are so good that's how we
got that huge tv deal 160 million for
four years like i said
solely because of the work that i did
and all of us but to build the stars so
that's my job is to be giving had i not
been giving
we might have not got that television
deal we might not be in business today
so it's my job to be giving and it's the
it's the most important thing for me to
do at this point in my career
uh to spread this
star power to as many
guys and girls that i can you do you do
seem relentlessly positive and i think
that's that's what a lot of people do
like about you i think a lot of your
colleagues like the same
but was was there ever a moment where
you were a bit like
i have given quite a lot here you know
you'll be like [__] this i'm gonna be
the the guy who acts like you know i
remember one time i had a hair versus
hair match against kevin nash
and it was i think in grand rapids
michigan
and i was trying to put together this
matchup i don't remember if nash wasn't
there if he was like not
interested in and nash kev is is a great
guy and [__] nothing but respect and
love for him but at the time he was
something was wrong with him that day
and he was something like i can't
remember exactly but i remember thinking
[__] this
i'm sick of trying to be the guy that
puts together the match and be the guy
that makes this [__] dude look good
if he doesn't care i don't care i'll go
out there and have a [__] shitty
match i don't give a [__] i said that to
pat patterson
i'm gonna go there and have a shitty
match i don't care and pat goes no you
won't i said what do you mean pat he
goes you
you can't
you don't have it in your dna
to go and have a shitty match you care
too much
and he was right
i care too much so
maybe sometimes you get frustrated and
angry and pissed off but once again this
is big business so be a be a man pull up
your pants and be a man
and um you're quite a brave guy well you
have to be to be in this business
you know you have to be i heard you once
stood up the brock lesnar yeah i did how
did
can you i didn't [__] stand up to him
again right now in the moment what i i
believe you what uh what led to that
happening he was doing a match with
randy orton and he was
basically like just butchering him with
elbows to the head
and i didn't know if it was planned or
not and nobody would tell me if it was
planned or not and listen
wrestling is is a hard-hitting sport but
elbows to the side of the head
can kill you your temple if you get hit
hard enough in the temple you die
especially with brock lesnar well yeah
but especially with anything have you
ever heard of david and goliath that's
how goliath died from getting a [__]
rock to his temple
so
it was very good though when he was
hitting him with the with the with the
elbows i was just like if this is real
uh it's [__] if it's been called
it's still [__] he's taken liberties
and it pissed me off
and i was in gorilla and i was [__]
angry about it and brock came through
and he saw me
angry about it and decided he wanted to
come challenge me and we got into a
little bit of an issue
and i was like [__] this guy i don't
give a [__] how big he's like i don't
[__] care it's [__] wrong and i
will fight to the death if i if i will
stand up for what i believe in to the
death and i remember being like
literally nose to nose with the guy and
he's laughing and he's like you know he
was actually saying things that would
probably get him canceled if i said if i
said them to
like homophobic terms that you shouldn't
be saying [__] um
and i was like [__] it how did that make
you feel i was like [__] i'm gonna bite
his [__] nose off i'm gonna bite his
nose off like i see this you made a
giant fat nose and i'm like
if he comes any closer and takes a swing
on me i'm literally i'm not even i'm not
even saying it as a as a tough guy i'm
literally going to bite his [__] nose
off and i can see it right now and i
remember king haku had done that it was
it was a was a good friend of mine he's
a good friend and i bit someone's nose
off once i'm like i'll bite his [__]
nose off see how tough he is then he
might kill me but he's gonna walk around
for the rest of his life with no [__]
nose so that's how it made me feel i
didn't care about the homophobic thing i
don't give a [__] i wasn't i wasn't
falling for it
right i was just yeah this has gone to
the next level now this is [__]
kill or be killed uh-huh and i'm going
to bite your [__] nose off and then
it got broken triple h tried to break
break it up we both told him to [__] off
which was hilarious
and then vince got involved and that and
that's kind of he got involved and
basically
you know
broke it up
and told me that he had told brock to do
that but no one else would say anything
before that and whatever whatever the
reasoning was that's between brock and
randy and vince none of my business but
when it got down to the to the
you know the
confrontation it was real you know and
it in
you know had it gone to the next step i
i swear to god i would have bitten his
nose off you could crush my face but i
will bite your nose have you ever bit
someone's nose off have you ever had
someone take liberties with you
in the ring though where you've where
you've had words afterwards and then
what the [__] was it really early on in
my career
it happened a few times
especially when you went to other
countries when you i remember in japan
it happened in mexico what happened but
once again then you just go back to you
know i grew up playing pro uh playing
hockey
you know someone gets caught up yeah and
[__] body check them or punch them in
the face or whatever it may be so if
someone's taking liberties with you like
one time is a mistake two times
coincidence three times okay now he's
now he's doing this for okay on purpose
and then you just gotta stop it and
because most bullies how do you stop it
just punch them back let them know that
i'm not playing this game with you well
actually you're in a compilation of for
a good reason on uh i've seen this the
other day on youtube of uh wrestlers who
saved another wrestler i don't know if
you know this but there's a moment where
jeff hardy documentaries yeah i mean i
do my research there's a moment jeff
hardy's doing uh some sort of moonsault
off the ropes and it doesn't go right
and he slips and you sort of
push him
and in that moment you react so fast and
you are so switched on and if you don't
push him the guy could have broken his
neck or anything
um
you know is that common for you is that
you're constantly trying to look after
them i don't think it's like yes
you look after each other
and
the jeff hardy one it's not like i had
some kind of a revelation of like i must
save this man but you even made it look
like a moo like like you were hurting
him but in reality part of being a pro
it was genius things happen in the match
you know like
the thing the [__] word i hate the
most that fans use is botch
oh you botched that one shut your
[__] mouth there's no such thing as a
botch this is a live
show
mistakes happen because why because
we're human beings and we're live if
it's a movie i bet you there's a million
mistakes in every movie and you take two
take five take 20 take 50. we have one
take so if someone falls down you [__]
up [__] you i'll punch you in your
[__] face for saying that yeah
people made a mistake but it's not like
embarrassing yeah it sucks
it we wish it didn't happen but it's
live especially with jeff hardy i mean
he tries all sorts it's not always going
to be it's all the time yeah if you
watch like a hockey game or a football
game you know guys skating down the ice
and takes a shot at the open net and
misses the net how does that happen you
think that guy doesn't wish he had
another chance at it but it's done
if it happens in a hockey game the fans
don't already start chanting in unison
you [__] up you [__] up
if you go to a broadway play and someone
fumbles their lines people don't start
chanting you [__] up you [__] up
you go to a wrestling match and miss a
hip toss people start chanting that it's
[__] it's [__] disrespectful and
wrestling fans walk the line of being
disrespectful and it's like mike tyson
said everybody's
you know
uh
uh you know everybody's got a [__]
opinion on social media but you would
never say that to somebody's face and
the same thing sitting in the crowd hall
of fame w hall of fame and people are
[__]
booing the bushwhackers for being in the
hall of fame [__] you mm-hmm i remember
them they weren't like two of my first
action figures you always say that yeah
did you know that yeah yeah yeah but
people were making fun of those guys for
getting the hall of fame at the hall of
fame ceremony how dare you i can't
believe that how dare you go back and
watch it they're chanting and saying
[__] or whatever it was so that to me is
like yeah i love wrestling fans if it
was if there were no fans there'd be no
career for chris jericho but you guys
got to keep it in check sometimes and
show some respect there's a weird line
in there yeah yeah and it's the
pantomime element of it yeah so anyway
so
botch there is no botch there's mistakes
that happen because it's alive and
people have died in that ring so that
for that reason the respect should be
there because always yeah you're putting
your bodies on the line and
and it's surprising how easy the things
have gone wrong in the past like i've
seen
like some of these videos where guys
have died there in the middle of
wrestling moves and stuff like i think
there was guys die guys get paralyzed
you guys get hurt really badly you know
i mean we just had the blood and guts
the other day was some of the most
insane things you'll ever see and
santana tears you know
i'm not i don't even know what the
injury is i don't want to say it but
whatever the injury was he [__] up his
knee from doing a simple rock bottom
yeah it's not on top of a cage it's not
falling off a cage just not getting hit
with a barbed wire or bat or whatever
it's doing a wrestling move and he's out
for eight months so it happens there's
the mental health issue of it as well
from the research i've been doing is
like you look at uh
jeff hardy i mentioned him like clearly
uh put his body on the line for years
but also his mind is obviously taken uh
it's taking the toll on him uh
you you've wrestled jeff uh a lot i
would imagine um well 20 years ago but i
haven't wrestled him since then really
okay well what do you what do you make
of it when a wrestler is
publicly in the ring not in a fit state
wrestle and
that's well it's one of i've been fairly
lucky and i've never experienced that if
i did i'd end the match
instantly really okay you have to yeah
you know um
and that's once again being
you know alcoholism or you know drug
addiction and all those things i mean it
is
a disease so
um i've never
wrestled drunk
and never as far as i know wrestled at
anybody that was drunk so but if it ever
happened like i said you would have to
end it quickly because you could get
hurt you could hurt each other yeah it
is unprofessional and jeff would
probably be the first one to tell you
that it seems like it's the pain that
you guys have suffered uh that that
leads them down this road it's like i'm
in pain and then they start with the
pain pills and then
they mix that with some alcohol and
before they know it that's a routine and
even brock lesnar mentioned that when he
came into the ufc he said it's actually
healthier for me being in a cage getting
punched in what it is being on the road
in wrestling because that's actually way
harder to do regularly you know in the
ufc you kind of go into that they're
gone fighting fit and
uh you don't have to keep doing it in
front of everyone week after week the
maintenance yeah that's right
um how do you like how do you maintain
your body when you're out on the road
because you're just sort of you're
traveling hotel traveling hotel it must
be a real challenge for you guys yeah
but it's not hard once you learn how to
do it right you know i mean you just if
you're on a diet you just bring your
food with you you know and you you know
sleep when you're tired and eat when
you're hungry and that sort of thing so
that's never been an issue for me being
on the road i've been on the road since
i was 19. so you can use that as an
excuse right but but you can also make
it work it just depends what mindset you
have one person i want to discuss with
you uh one of the biggest shocks for me
was a wrestling fan
was chris benoit
um
i was a big fan as most people were at
that point and obviously the eddie
guerrero death and then his death in
that year you were close with both of
them when i watched your early years you
wrestled them a lot and seemed really
tight with them
i mean for losing both of them
how did that impact you and especially
the chris one like it was such a a
bizarre
thing to happen that it didn't seem like
anyone could have seen that coming no i
mean that's that was what made it so
horrible is is
nobody saw it coming um chris was a
great guy you know and he was an
honorable guy like if i
had to leave my kids with somebody for
the weekend
on an emergency i would have no problems
leaving them with chris so
um
to this day we still don't know why you
know and you'll never know why and
you know i've heard every theory right
even demonic possession like every
theory in between um is there an
accepted theory amongst his friends and
peers that
this is what we think happened that's a
great question but i don't really think
so because none of us really there was
the brain damage thing that a lot of
people were pushing still i understand
that but
and listen
to kill his wife
is
beyond comprehension
but
killing your own son that to me is the
one where it gets it gets to me so
uh that's the you know and like i said
it's that's the unforgive forgivable
portion of the whole story to me
um and i feel like when people are
mentally so ill
they have these notions of i'm taking
him with me
sort of thing yeah that's that's one of
the theories that people put forward for
when people do that yeah once once i
said we can analyze it until the cows
come home yeah bottom line is
i don't know what happened we'll never
know and it's a terrible tragedy
uh because
in s at the end of the day chris was a
great friend of mine you know and
he was a great family man as well so
we'll never know what happened um
and
we just have to move forward maybe
thinking of the good part of his life
which was
everything up until that last weekend
and that's the way i look at it from a
professional standpoint it's hard for me
to watch a jericho bama match but i'll
talk about them all day long because
that's part of my career some some of my
greatest matches involved him so i have
to continue to think about him in that
respect
uh but still very angry and never will
understand what happened so
you wrestle china a lot and i really
remembered that quite vividly because i
remember finding it so believable that
this woman was beating the hell out of
this man and a lot of people said that
that was one of the ways that the wa in
the back kind of gave you a lot of
credit like he's really carrying her and
he's doing such a great job with her and
it felt like he proved a lot what was it
like wrestling china terrible really she
was terrible to work with um
she wasn't good but she thought she was
and she also was in a position where
they were pushing her really big that
she could beat up guys
she couldn't
obviously and and like
um
i never got that credit no one ever once
said you're making her look good it was
it was the other side of the coin oh i
got in big trouble from working with her
because at one point i remember when i
first started working with her
vince was like
don't treat her like a woman treat her
like a wrestler
and
she was really stiff too
which means she worked very strong
listen
and i'm not saying talking bad of her
i'm just telling the truth so when we
work together it was a solid fight in a
lot of ways and i remember one time she
got a little bit of a black eye from me
and you would have thought i'd cut her
arm off with a chainsaw like i got in so
much trouble and i was like [__] like i
would i didn't do it on purpose but i
mean they're having you wrestle her what
are they what do you expect
so um it was it was a tough position for
me to be in it was my first real angle
in the wwe my first story
um
but but once again i mean i did the best
that i could and i think her best
matches that she ever had were with me
absolutely
hopefully prove something to the people
that had to prove things too but there
was a lot of issues
with working with her yeah that's so
fascinating because
when i was watching this documentary i
was like
like i remember that angle so clearly
you're making this documentary sound
like a [__] masterpiece
yeah it sounds amazing
i also i was kind of like wow china was
kind of hot i kind of no don't even
don't act like you just realized that
because it's on an almost weekly basis
that you mentioned that what no well
stephanie mcmahon was my sort of right
yeah yeah i like the boss's daughter
vibe oh yeah if i was triple h i would
have done the same thing i would have
been like
i see what you're doing here to be fair
if you were triple h i don't think you
pulled off was there skepticism of
triple h when that was the the affair
happened and obviously he left china for
stephanie where people like see what
you're doing there causing the bosses
that are all people people just like
[__] talking about this now i don't know
if people have that kind of banter
backstage yeah man i mean i i i
would love to tell you that there was a
huge discussion about it but it was kind
of like
it's really none of my business yeah
yeah exactly it happens and [__]
whatever i mean what does it matter to
me you know is there a lot of
politicking between wrestlers in that
sense like do you guys talk a lot or is
it literally just hey you're paired up
with him get in the ring go practice
this how does it work there's yeah
there's a lot of politicking but um
you know like i said like it like
it it's like the mjf thing that's going
on people ask me about it like if it
doesn't directly relate to me i stay out
of it well can you explain that because
i've i've this guy has invaded my social
media so he's doing something right this
mjf character right like i'm an old
school wrestling fan so when there's a
big wrestling event on i'll pay
attention but but this guy he cut a
promo where he seemed to go
off script and a lot of people were
saying it was good but
when you're saying this controversy what
is that sorry well once again like my
point was
whatever issue that he has and the
reason why he cut the promo and all the
other thing is like it's got nothing to
do with me so i stay out of it um
is it an angle is it a story
maybe
but whatever issues there like it
doesn't affect me either way so that's
something for fans to debate and for me
it's like well if it's an angle and it
pays off by making us money then it
worked
if it doesn't make us money and doesn't
make him a bigger star well then it
really didn't it's definitely it's
definitely increased his profile because
it's got people talking i mean i know
who he is now and and
generally speaking like
you know with him being with aaw
i am less aware of their wrestlers than
wa because they their financial push
they can push who they want you know
what i mean i've got no interest in
roman reigns but i can't go anywhere
without seeing his face right um so the
kid did something well in terms of like
old school wrestling versus new school
it feels like to me at least
the
believability and the blurred lines of
reality versus what's scripted back in
the day it it felt like those lines were
a lot more blurred and now if you watch
the wwe you can see it's they're reading
things verbatim almost and it is quite
forced sometimes
whereas maybe with aw it's they're going
in a bit of a different direction what
what are you saying is the future of of
wrestling now where where are we headed
because people are i think tired of this
pg
sort of era
well i mean i i think what aw has done
is is
show people that there is room for an
alternative and it was time
you can't just have a monopoly of one
wrestling company or you know one rock
and roll band or one football team or
whatever maybe so i think having the
variety and having another company
really was the right place and the right
time
to do it and that's why we've gone
through the roof i mean i think here in
the uk
our show dynamite is the number one
wrestling show more than raw not
surprised more than smackdown
same in canada so that just proves the
point that
people were ready for an alternative so
what's the future of it i don't know but
i do know that right now i think the
business is very strong
because of aw because there's another
place to go
if you get mad at wwe and you're
wrestling fan well come check us out if
you get mad at aw then go watch wwe so
it's good to have that it's good to have
that uh
alternative that that competition
uh and the choice and that's what we
provide we we give people a choice
uh if you don't like this then you can
watch us and that's really proven to be
successful when you come out and they
play i've seen some videos of you coming
out and they played judaism is it in the
documentary it wasn't actually this was
just me just doing more browsing um when
you'd first dropped judas it was a real
special moment like i could see the
smile on your face when you come out and
the fans are belting this tune out and
singing every it was like 20 000 people
singing word for word and that was the
first for like wrestling where a
wrestler had made a track
it's his entrance music and everyone's
singing word for word you had this
massive smile on your face like
well it's more of like um
acknowledgement you know
and you're right it is very unique it is
something that no one has ever really
had before and that's why i like when i
turned heel
a few months ago and people were like
well why you still use judas it's such a
baby phase song well it doesn't matter
heal or baby face it's a very unique
moment that you can only see in aw the
only place where people are going to be
singing along
to
a wrestler's theme song
especially the theme song that that
wrestler sang
is here in aw so
you don't want to cut off your nose to
spite your face and to not use judas
anymore would have been a crime and
because and we discussed it of using a
different song but tony was like no
let's keep using it because you can only
see this in aw and it is very cool and
it's one of the reasons why like i said
i think judas went gold
um it was a hit before we started using
naw
but the fact that you could hear it live
every wednesday with people singing
along to it
even without music
as we had in houston last year um it's
very special and you could only see that
in our company on our show so yeah it's
an amazing it's it's amazing for me to
um
experience that because it's like this
is [__] you forget it's my [__] song
and everyone is singing it on their own
and they know the words and it's just
it's just really cool there was one
moment where you came up without the
song and they sang it
word for word acapella yeah right out of
the game [__] crazy yeah it was it
was it was um
mgf had put this stipulation that i
couldn't use my my song that week i am
sweating like a [__] that's hot
because all right
yeah i think were you boozing last night
a little bit that it helps it it helps
come out yeah yeah yeah i was drinking
that uh
what was i gonna say um this tony
character
how does he uh how does he differ to um
vince as a boss well he's younger
so he's more excited about things
um i love working for tony con he's very
passionate he's very smart
he's not
when it first started it's like oh
tony khan is a money mark as they would
say
um meaning he just gives out money for
no reason not the case he's very smart
with his money he runs
fulham football club here
he has a lot to do with the jacksonville
jaguars the nfl so he knows big business
and big sports and that's how he treats
aw
um so yeah he's
he's very passionate
um
he's got a lot of things on his plate so
sometimes it's hard to get in touch with
him
but he is a great boss because he cares
so much vince cares too but once again
you're dealing with a guy that's been
doing it for 40 years in comparison with
a guy who's been doing it for three
years
so um
there's there's a different level of
excitement from tony do you still party
hard at the search well this this is not
party trust me it wasn't like i went to
computers this is just really [__]
hot so thank you yeah i just wondered
because you are you're a rock star yeah
you've got to give a rough shot
but i also enjoy the moderation of it
you know i never had to check myself
into rehab or anything longer yeah yeah
fair play and and listen you can't be on
the road and not
you know
have some fun from here there but but
you got to be cool with it you got to be
smart you know you're in a nice part of
london as well so you can still go out
and just enjoy some drinks
and still have fun oh no believe me i
know that yeah well welcome
it's a joke it's lovely yeah
a lot of that moderation doesn't it's
not all the other wrestlers have seen
struggle with that for sure
it's definitely part of it isn't it yeah
yeah moderation has always i think i
guess some of the other wrestlers we've
spoken to like spoken to undertaker
spoken to shortly as well yeah they're
spoken about how other people
i think there was a time where maybe wwe
had a bit of a or wrestling in general
had a bit of a problem with people being
able to moderate themselves and kind of
manage their own what was your sort of
um experience around others i never had
a problem with with like the big thing
in wrestling that caused a lot of issues
was pills
never
took pills ever never i've never i've
never been a drug guy um
so that kind of helped a lot you know
uh drinking sure but but never got into
pills and and the drugs so i think that
was something that kind of probably
enabled me to still do this
you know 32 years in
was i was never an addict for that sort
of thing um but when you're witnessing
in other people like how do you think
though
i'm not really trying to get anything
specific i'm just really more talking
about your experience of it where you
know you might see someone else
struggling with it did you ever see that
or is it something that people most
people kept quite private in a way
private you know and unless it was just
part of the culture right you know um
you know if you look at 80s 90s
wrestling look at 80s 90s rock and roll
a lot of those guys died too it was just
it was different then
now it's not so much you know you don't
see a lot of guys doing drugs drugs are
kind of
in the past bit blase now you know yeah
and that's good um it's funny because
people bag and all the guys want to do
is play video games now it's like well
so is that so bad you know it's better
than going out and getting [__] up
every night and you know
doing things you shouldn't be doing so
um i think that's another reason why
wrestling has changed and and guys are
so much better athletes now uh-huh um
yeah rick flair is going to wrestle
again i saw yeah [__]
fair player what is he 70
73 jesus but once again it's the
attraction we'll see how it goes so um
once again good for him you want to do
it go for it who am i to say don't do it
who am i to say oh what is he doing well
[__] it who cares yeah it's very i think
it's very much they're doing it like uh
like an old box of having one last
exhibition which i kind of like the the
idea of that providing obviously yeah
safe yeah people love it
were you on the plane right from hell
no
oh
i read about this where um it all kicked
off on a plane ride in the wa and i
think brock lesnar and kurt angle were
like fighting on a plane and there was
[__] all sorts great actually a uh
exit uh
uh
yeah i mean once again
it was a little bit of a different world
uh back in those days because that was
20 odd years ago yeah you know guys
would get a little bit crazier back then
but now um the guy's a little bit more
responsible
and um and that's good it's just it's
more longevity
and we had way too many guys dying young
and that's kind of thankfully stopped
now so yeah it does it's definitely
slowed down obviously we lost uh scott
hall in the last year but obviously that
was something that was very long term
long-term
situation with him but he was still from
that same generation
so
you know i i think that's a good legacy
for for the modern day
um
wrestler is that
the partying and that sort of self-abuse
has really gone down
what about your like family life and
that because it must be so hard to
maintain
you know these relationships that mean a
lot to you when you're either on the
road wrestling or on the road performing
in your band well once again it's not as
bad as it was because for aw we only
work once a week now all right so
you're home a lot more and when fozzie
goes on tour obviously you're gone
longer but um
we've got it down to a science now like
if we're in the states we do five shows
a week with two days off i go home for
those two days
so i'm home every week at least we don't
go to europe longer than than than two
weeks now back in the past it was three
and a half four weeks that's that's done
i won't do it so you just kind of
prioritize and when you say to your you
know agents and managers
we're only doing two weeks it makes for
a better tour they find better gigs you
know whereas if you're saying
you know three four weeks they'll put
you in any you know we're
in grimsby tonight you know right on
we're in middlesboro and now it's like
we're not in those cities um
because we just do bigger ones because
there's less states available so
newcastle over middlesbrough you go to
the good bit but yeah we actually always
go to newcastle newcastle's awesome
but i'm from
i could tell and not that middlesbrough
is not awesome but you see my point you
have to do the bigger gigs because you
have less time available and so that's
you you pick your spot which which
really is the smart move to do it's a
little bit like dave chappelle says
though it's like you know his kids look
at him when he gets back of a tour and
they're like oh mr promises back from
the road it's like you know how do your
kids see you you know are they like oh
god it's dad who's that cheesy wrestler
is it like oh daddy's like cool rock
style so what what's the
no it's just dad you know and then
that's that's what i've always been to
them right i remember my dad played pro
hockey for 10 years what did he play new
york rangers l.a kings and st louis was
the nhl wow and i was
you know
never really understood what the big
fuss was
oh your dad plays in the nhl it's
amazing yeah but he's just my dad you
know
and um now
i realize how cool it is now i go on
youtube and look up ted irvine and
there's a gor those goals that he scored
and the fights that he was in and all
that sort of thing but
to me it was always just dad and that's
the same with my kids
none of them show much interest in
wrestling
they don't think it's cool and they
think the music is cool but like if i
you know uh
like dad
do you know that snoop dogg follows you
on instagram
yeah i've known snoop dogg you know
snoop dogg yeah [__] i know snoop dogg
like he's [__] always cool are we
best friends no but we know each other
and that makes me cool to them that that
i know these famous people but other
than that i'm just dad and that's the
way it should be and that's the way i
like it what kind of dad would you say
you are
a good one
involved
um do you think that do you see bits of
yourself in because you're a creative
guy you're an athletic guy are you
looking for like little elements of that
in your kids
a little bit but but kids kids
need to find their way need to find
their own path and like i said none of
them have ever shown any interest in
being a wrestler or being a musician or
being in the public eye and that's fine
if if none of them do that
that's cool they'll find
their own paths of what they want to be
and what they want to do so um
i think what i've imparted into all of
them is confidence
and um
the
ambition to
to find what they want to do and and the
i guess the uh
the motto if you have a dream follow it
and will support you a thousand percent
whatever that dream might be it might
not be pro wrestling or going to music
but if it's wanting to be a veterinarian
or whatever let's let's go for that so i
think i think
my kids have always known that they got
a great support system
to go and find themselves and whatever
they want to do they can do it do they
ever come and travel with you on toes
and stuff they don't people ask that but
it's still fun for them if i have my
kids or what would they be doing right
now that's a [__] question you know what
yeah
that's not a [__] question but it's just
one of those things where like
life on the road is not easy
and kids especially
they like uh routines and they want to
be around their friends they don't be
hanging around with their dad you know
waiting around all day or
hanging around in some city or something
watching a poke costume yeah hang out
with their friends and doing their own
thing that's how it should be what's
your creative process because clearly
you have a lot of creativity to reinvent
yourself as a wrestler to think of
lyrics to write songs all of these
things
how do you come up with things
i don't know it's the muse
you know it's
i remember
reading a stephen king
story where people where do you get your
ideas it's like i don't know where do
the ideas come from
they just come
we did blood and guts the other day and
i came up with a whole finishing
sequence while i was kickboxing it just
came into my head
and i remember it was like
one two
and you kind of go into another world
for a bit
and you have this whole idea same thing
with fozzie with a song lyrics or
a concept
a stage show a set list
it just kind of comes to you
if you try and come up with an idea and
sit there with a pencil and a paper and
force yourself it doesn't work you know
what i mean if you can't think of a
finish for a match or
a lyric for a song
then just leave it
it always comes it always does
i feel like it's a gift imagination it's
like some just have it some don't yeah
there are some people who as you say
with those uh older bands that are still
doing it they just it just keeps coming
and coming because it's
just they they're connected are you a
bit of an anglophile like i asked you
that before but i don't i think we
stopped but like you see whenever i
watch you speak you always have these
little
english words that you drop in well so
i'm from canada right yeah so canada and
england are basically sister countries
and we have the cbc
which is our version of the bbc
so i grew up with english tv shows
english comedy what sort of things did
you watch when you faulty towers is the
greatest show of all time
to this day yeah it still is
i mean it is yeah everything that ricky
gervais does is based on basil fault yes
i mean why'd you have to stay for just
an hour because now we're unlocking the
good [__] this is the next this yeah
so um but growing up with that you have
that english
slant to it the sentiment of it yeah
yeah you kind of did something where
once where you were you were coming out
of coming out as your entrance but they
followed you through the back and you
got lost or something like that you had
that basically like the character you
were playing it was kind of give a c in
that you were delusional that was spinal
tap yeah that came from from spinal tap
which is another kind of english
influence comedy um and you'll see a lot
of that throughout my whole career
and in my whole kind of
genetic makeup
is is the
english sense of humor which is
basically the canadian sense of humor
where you're very dry uh
but you play things straight you always
play it straight and that's one thing i
love i do it all the time in aw if you
ask anybody that works with me inner
circle guys jericho appreciation society
guys
play it straight if you make it into a
joke it's not funny if you play it
straight that's where the humor comes
yeah yes and and and that
reminds me of a scene that you and stone
cold did where clearly were you the heel
and that's why i like you when you're
the heel because you can say the most
ridiculous [__] with a straight face and
you could say that austin's like looking
at you and you're saying things and
you know like you can do it too though
that's his sense yeah as well yeah and
when you get those type of guys that's
where the true candidates was so good
man and you could see he almost burst
yeah i like watching that
what's dave like because like he
obviously changed wrestling like the
biggest guy
ever very intense
uh very funny and a great guy he's one
of the few guys that still
picks up a phone and calls somebody
he'll call me
and when he calls you
you better have 60 minutes to
talk because it's a long conversation
not a texting guy
he wants to talk to you he's old school
yeah and uh yeah
great guy one of my all-time favorite
people that i've met in the wrestling
business for sure the whole family
they trained you
i've heard about the dungeon and old man
heart and all of that what was that
experience like learning it from some of
the greatest well the thing is
the reason why
um i've always been good in the ring is
i was trained properly
and i had a great foundation
you have to learn your basics you build
a house if you don't have a good
foundation the house collapses so it's
great to know how to do a moonsault off
the top rope and do a shooting star
press but if you don't know how to do a
lockup it really doesn't matter and you
know you'll see that in a lot of modern
wrestlers is the high spots are all
there and the athleticism is there but
i'll watch someone lock up sometimes to
go
i'm not into this match what do you mean
it's only been three seconds
yeah but the lock up sucked it started
shitty for me so i learned the
foundations properly from the hearts and
from
calgary which is a great wrestling
city
which hearts were you closest with um
really none of them
they're a very strange group i'd
probably say brett more than
addy probably maybe when you say that's
strange in what way that's the whole of
the podcast
it's a large family that grew up in the
wrestling business so
you know um i'm surprised brett became
the star he did actually when you when
you see him talk now or even when i
watch his prime he wasn't the talker i
suppose it was his in-ring ability that
that gave him that career and there was
a certain charisma that he had yeah he
had a look as well obviously yeah and
not everybody everybody has their own
style and he he knew who he was as a
performer and knew who he was as a
character and was able to portray that
that's the most important thing not
everybody's the same character nor
should they be do you think
he the screwdriver did do you think he
took that a little too much to heart no
pun intended to him no to him it meant
everything so
i can't talk about how brett
you know took it
or didn't too seriously because if i was
him
i would probably feel the exact same way
really okay
last question
how would you like to be remembered
just as somebody who
always entertained
um and always gave a thousand percent in
everything that i do because i take
great
uh
responsibility in knowing that people
are a giving me their time
to watch a match to listen to a song
to come to a show to listen to a podcast
whatever it is and be
paying money
uh i don't take that lightly you know i
remember when i was first starting out
in wrestling and somebody like this
match sucks and the guy will go yeah
well i got your money kid or whatever i
never looked at that well we've got
their money who cares about the product
people work too hard
to
feed their families and to make ends
meet so if they have extra money to
be entertained then i bet i damn we'll
better entertain them and if you've been
out drinking
excuse me the night before or if you're
tired if you're pissed off or whatever
maybe
suck it up
you've got a responsibility because you
know these people have been waiting
for i don't know six months three months
four months
looking forward to this show
so if you go on stage and like [__] i
gotta sing judas again they've never
heard judas live they want to sing it
and they want to be there
so you have to give your all
to everything that you do
um so yeah i would like to be remembered
as someone who just
gave it his all to make sure that you
were entertained and if you've ever been
entertained by chris jericho in any way
shape or form and enjoyed what i did
well then i take great pride in that
certainly have thank you very much that
was chris jericho on the true jordy
podcast uh we'll put the links in the
description below if you want to go to
see chris live or you want to follow the
wrestling if you want to be entertained
by chris
yeah let him entertain you yeah that's
the legacy and we'll see you on the next
one cheers